all right let's hear from a couple of
other people why don't we go to is it
Cayenne from Queens
yeah that's Cayenne how are you
doing uh so my first question uh is
related to how Biden is doing
um I'm a pretty uh left Progressive and
uh when when Biden won I was still kind
of hopeful there was some talk of him
being
about having these at uh FDR aspirations
yeah but over the past few months I feel
like
um
he hasn't really been talking about much
uh that has been important to
progressives like climate change
Healthcare or a minimum wage just kind
of out the window disappeared so
I'm one I'm wondering um do you think
he's starting to feel like it's okay to
just
abandon uh these things that are
important to the progressive base and
uh an existing like a similar question
but different perspective is
do you think he's okay is because
Americans don't really expect much from
government I mean uh
they're like okay with just how things
are and as long as you know they don't
have a an idiot like Trump being that
they're just like okay and they don't
expect much and do you think that's a
problem
um so I think that there are lots of
people who who no longer expect much
from government but the the thing we
have to be careful with that is that
there's a political movement which is
all about not expecting stuff from
government and that government should be
doing less so I think that that's
something we sort of want to be careful
of in terms of the language we use in
terms of Biden I mean listen I I think
that I'm not seeing any u-turns from
Biden what I am certainly seeing is he
hasn't yet done all of the things he
promised to do he's you know talked
about a public option that hasn't
happened there's other things uh he got
coveted relief passed he uh scaled up
vaccination now he's working on
infrastructure if he gets an
infrastructure deal done by September
1st it will be a pretty significant
first year in terms of major legislation
in conjunction with a lot of the
executive orders that he did early to
undo some of the stuff that Donald Trump
did is it a progressive dream no but I
never expected it to be so I my sense is
Biden's doing more or less what I
expected and I've not seen him abandon
anything he claimed he would do yet some
things he hasn't done yet right so we
have to give him a term to see if he
does it but I I feel like I'm getting
from Biden exactly what I expected
okay yeah I I'm also getting what I
expected like my mindset and the
primaries just like but he's not gonna
do much to satisfy progressives but
I don't know what happened I just had
some weird hope that uh in the beginning
like maybe he's are progressive than we
thought so that was probably not a good
way for me to think no no I I believed
from the beginning that he was exactly
who he said he was during the campaign
and that that's what I'm seeing so far
yeah so about the second question like
do you think that it's a problem that
Americans
oh
um you said I should watch my language
but
um I just feel like Americans are
satisfied they're like uh you know
but the Warfare instiller so you know if
you have a hard time seeing that other
countries have uh you know Universal
Health Care or free college tuition
um so they're just like okay with not
having that as long as
long as everything seems stable I think
there are lots of people who want those
things but after the four years we had
certainly the standard for just a
minimum that people expect which is like
a president that sort of seems normal
and doesn't alienate every other country
that we're allied with Etc the bar has
been dropped and we are adjusting to
that bar being dropped as that happens I
think it will be perfectly reasonable to
refocus exactly on the things you're
talking about that are that are more
common in northern European social
democracy so it's not a one or the other
it's we're adjusting to The New Normal
of being of having had Trump as
president for four years and I think
we're pretty close to being adjusted and
now it's time to get some stuff done
okay I appreciate your perspective and
thanks for having me on all right
Cayenne from Queens very much appreciate
the call that's gonna do it for today as
always sorry I couldn't get to everybody
but I will take more calls again very
soon